This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能逍遥法外。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。去听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into this episode, I just want to say a huge thank you for all of the support and the love and the kindness that you guys have shown the podcast and our video
后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要继续剖析20多岁的心理。在进入这一集之前，我只想对你们给予播客和我们视频的所有支持、爱和善意表示衷心的感谢
episodes being on Netflix. I'm going to be brutally honest and say that transition hasn't been all that easy for me emotionally and mentally. And I've definitely been experiencing a lot of self-doubt, a lot of panic, a lot of anxiety, a lot of pressure in the past few months. And I feel like I have to be honest with you guys about that as the people who have been here since day one. I know it's very easy to see like big accomplishments like the one that the podcast has gone through. And especially in your 20s to think that it's all incredible and spectacular. And a large part of it has been spectacular, but it's also been very hard. And you guys have just been the silver lining and have continued
在Netflix上播出的剧集。我要坦诚地说，从情感和心理上讲，这种转变对我来说并不容易。在过去的几个月里，我确实经历了很多自我怀疑、恐慌、焦虑和压力。我觉得我必须对你们诚实，因为你们是从第一天起就一直在这里的人。我知道，看到播客所取得的巨大成就，尤其是在20多岁的时候，很容易认为这一切都是不可思议和壮观的。其中很大一部分确实很壮观，但也非常艰难。而你们一直是那道银边，并继续
to make it so special. Every time you guys tag me in your Instagram stories, watching an episode on Netflix, or message me saying, you've seen it. Message me saying, like, when is it coming to my country? Or you leave a comment, it is just the best feeling ever. So I just, I feel like I haven't said it enough on the podcast. Thank you for making this so special for me. And if you haven't watched an episode yet on Netflix and you are in the US or Canada, you can go and search up the psychology of your 20s right now. Hopefully it will be in many other countries soon. No promises, but fingers crossed. Without further ado, let's get into today's episode. Today, my friends, we are talking about homesickness. That deep sadness and melancholydened.
让它变得如此特别。每当你们在Instagram故事中标记我，观看Netflix上的剧集，或者给我发信息说你们已经看过了。给我发信息说，比如，它什么时候会在我的国家上映？或者你们留下评论，这真的是最好的感觉。所以我只是觉得我在播客里说得还不够。感谢你们让这一切对我来说如此特别。如果你还没有在Netflix上观看过剧集，并且你在美国或加拿大，你可以现在去搜索《20多岁的心理学》。希望它很快能在许多其他国家上线。不敢保证，但祈祷吧。废话不多说，让我们进入今天的话题。今天，朋友们，我们要谈谈思乡之情。那种深深的悲伤和忧郁
collie we get from being away from home for just a bit too long, the desire to run back to where we feel the safest, the sick feeling in our stomach, the anxiety we get when the sun goes down, the only place you want to be is not where you are, that kind of homesickness, the kind that I'm sure you can all relate to, that we've all experienced at some point in our 20s, at some point in our life, the best way that I've seen homesickness described is as a mini-grief. even when the reason you're away from home is a good thing, is a great thing. Even when it's because you've gone to college or you're moving on with your life or you're traveling to places that you only ever dreamed about, you've moved cities for like an
当我们离家太久时，那种想要跑回我们感到最安全的地方的渴望，胃里那种恶心的感觉，太阳下山时感到的焦虑，你唯一想去的地方不是你现在所在的地方，那种思乡之情，我相信你们都能感同身受，我们在20多岁时，在人生的某个阶段都经历过，我所见过的对思乡之情最好的描述是“微型悲伤”。即使你离家的原因是一件好事，一件伟大的事情。即使是因为你上了大学，或者你正在继续你的生活，或者你正在前往你梦寐以求的地方，你为了一个
amazing opportunity for love, there is still this recognition that you are saying goodbye to something and a way of living and a way of existing. that is really comfortable and familiar and that you love. You're grieving things maybe never being the same again. You're grieving the security. You're grieving the past and you're missing not just the place, not just the location, but the memories. You're missing a system. You're missing a routine. You're missing relationships. Homestickness is so much more complicated and hard that I think a lot of people give it credit. That's what makes this also emotionally painful. It is a full body experience and today I feel like we need to just talk about it in depth. It's also strange because
为了爱情的绝佳机会搬到了其他城市，仍然有一种认识，那就是你在告别某样东西，一种生活方式和一种存在方式。那是真的很舒适、很熟悉，而且你很喜欢。你可能在为事情永远不会再一样而悲伤。你在为安全感而悲伤。你在为过去而悲伤，你怀念的不仅仅是那个地方，不仅仅是那个位置，而是那些记忆。你怀念一个系统。你怀念一种惯例。你怀念人际关系。思乡之情比我认为很多人给予的评价要复杂和困难得多。这就是为什么它在情感上也如此痛苦。这是一种全身心的体验，今天我觉得我们需要深入探讨一下。这也很奇怪，因为
you also know in this period of life that you need to experience some heart emotions, homesickness being one of them, to grow. It's kind of the price you pay for getting out of your comfort zone and seeing the world. There are so many people who feel this way and who feel very frustrated but also feel very indebted to the experience and guilty. And it can be hard to enjoy the moment that you're in and also to see clearly how life is going and what you want in the future. And whether this is a place you should be or whether you should go home, it's a very confusing emotion. Let's really dive into it today and just break down the psychology, what it is, why it is so emotionally painful, when to listen to your homesickness, but also when to not listen to it.
你在这个人生阶段也知道，你需要经历一些艰难的情绪，思乡之情就是其中之一，才能成长。这算是你走出舒适区、看世界所付出的代价。有很多人有这种感觉，感到非常沮丧，但也对这种经历感到非常亏欠和内疚。很难享受你所处的当下，也很难清楚地看到生活的发展方向以及你未来想要什么。以及这是否是你应该待的地方，或者你是否应该回家，这是一种非常令人困惑的情绪。今天让我们真正深入探讨一下，剖析一下心理学，它是什么，为什么它在情感上如此痛苦，什么时候该听从你的思乡之情，但什么时候又不该听从它。
and also my tips are the things that you could do today, the things you could do tomorrow, the things you could do this week that I can guarantee will make you feel better. So without further ado, let's get into it. So let's begin with this. Why are you feeling so homesick right now? You're feeling homesick right now because your mind and your body is programmed to avoid drastic changes. and to make you very much aware that it doesn't like drastic changes when they happen, whether you like it or not. There is this fascinating study from 2012 looking at university students that found homesickness isn't just like a pesky, annoying feeling.
还有我的建议，你可以今天做的事情，明天可以做的事情，这周可以做的事情，我保证会让你感觉更好。所以废话不多说，让我们开始吧。那么让我们从这里开始。为什么你现在感到如此思乡？你现在感到思乡是因为你的大脑和身体被编程为避免剧烈变化。并让你非常清楚地意识到，当剧烈变化发生时，它不喜欢这样，无论你是否喜欢。2012年有一项关于大学生的迷人研究发现，思乡之情不仅仅是一种恼人的、烦人的感觉。
It's actually a stress response. Your body, your mind, your nervous system likes certainty, likes knowing, likes safety, likes safety, because that is where you can flourish best. What is most known? What is most safe? What is most certain? Home. Home, your routines, your childhood bedroom,
它实际上是一种压力反应。你的身体、你的大脑、你的神经系统喜欢确定性，喜欢知情，喜欢安全，喜欢安全，因为那是你能发挥得最好的地方。什么是众所周知的？什么是安全的？什么是确定的？家。家，你的惯例，你童年的卧室，
the space you decompress every single night, the environment where you know exactly what to expect. That is where your body and your mind always wants you to go back to. Every single human needs some version of this. It is wide. into our DNA and into our way of being to have a home base or to have some environment or some space where we feel our safest and where we can just switch off for the day, for the month, for the hour.
你每天晚上放松的空间，你确切知道会发生什么的环境。那是你的身体和大脑总是想让你回去的地方。每一个人类都需要这种东西的某种版本。它被写入了我们的DNA和我们的存在方式中，拥有一个大本营，或者拥有某种环境或空间，在那里我们感到最安全，在那里我们可以为这一天、这一月、这一小时关掉开关。
That is why we literally have something called place attachment theory, this idea, this idea from psychologists and scientists that we form deep emotional bonds with places. That is something that we are hardwired to do. The same way that we form deep emotional bonds with people. And like people, certain places become part of who you are. They become part of how you see yourself. They hold really precious memories. They hold your routines.
这就是为什么我们字面上有一种东西叫做“地方依恋理论”，这个想法，这个来自心理学家和科学家的想法，即我们与地方建立了深厚的情感纽带。这是我们天生就会做的事情。就像我们与人建立深厚的情感纽带一样。而且像人一样，某些地方成为了你的一部分。它们成为了你看待自己方式的一部分。它们承载着非常珍贵的记忆。它们承载着你的惯例。
They hold your sense of safety. They also are what hold our default self, the person that we are at our core, the person we most naturally become when we feel our safest, normally at home. Even for nomads, right? Even for people who give the impression of needing nothing, just like the wide open space. Like the wide open road, the wide open spaces are for them home. There is not a human alive that doesn't have some or need some kind of environmental or external consistency,
它们承载着你的安全感。它们也是承载我们默认自我、我们核心自我的地方，当我们感到最安全时，我们最自然地成为的那个人，通常是在家里。即使对于游牧民族来说，对吧？即使对于那些给人一种什么都不需要、只喜欢广阔空间印象的人来说。就像广阔的道路，广阔的空间对他们来说就是家。没有一个活着的人不需要某种环境或外部的一致性，
even if that consistency is inconsistency. So when you leave those spaces and say goodbye, when you leave home, when you move a city, it is like a breakup. It's like a death. Your brain has to reprogram where to go to feel safe, what we can and can't trust, what makes us feel good, what feels normal for us now whilst managing the pain and the loss and the pain of nostalgia. Nostalgia and homesickness, by the way, incredibly similar emotions, something you may not know, the word nostalgia was initially created as a medical diagnostic term for sailors who were suffering
即使这种一致性是不一致的。所以当你离开这些空间并说再见时，当你离开家，当你搬到一个城市时，这就像一场分手。这就像一场死亡。你的大脑必须重新编程去哪里才能感到安全，我们可以信任什么，不能信任什么，什么让我们感觉良好，什么对我们来说现在感觉正常，同时还要处理痛苦、失落和怀旧的痛苦。顺便说一句，怀旧和思乡之情是非常相似的情绪，你可能不知道的一点是，怀旧这个词最初是作为一种医学诊断术语，用于那些患有
from homesickness. Literally, that was what the word for homesickness was, nostalgia. You want to know something else interesting? Another interesting psychology. History fact, nostalgia is one of the most intense emotions you can experience. It's also not distinctly good or distinctly bad, but when you feel it, researchers show that you really feel it, if you know what I mean. Like, you feel it like nothing else. And that's what you're enduring right now. Again, it's like a breakup. It's like a breakup where you idealize all the good things. You don't remember any of the bad things. Your brain has this natural positivity bias towards the past, towards home compared to the reality of the present, which is very colourful and vivid and real
思乡之情的船员。字面上，这就是思乡之情的词，怀旧。你想知道另一个有趣的事情吗？另一个有趣的心理学。历史事实，怀旧是你所能经历的最强烈的情绪之一。它也不是明显的好或明显的坏，但当你感觉到它时，研究人员表明你真的感觉到了，如果你明白我的意思的话。就像，你感觉到了它，就像没有其他东西一样。而这就是你现在正在忍受的。再说一次，这就像一场分手。这就像一场分手，你理想化了所有好的事情。你不记得任何坏的事情。你的大脑对过去、对家有一种自然的积极偏见，相比于现在的现实，它是非常丰富多彩、生动和真实的
that you are experiencing right now. And the rose-coloured glasses that we have for the past versus the accurate vision we have for the present means that the present feels a lot starker. Essentially, what this explanation basically says is that being away from your home, even for a great thing, even for a fantastic thing, is always initially going to mean that there will be a time where you don't have a strong place attachment that you can go home to immediately. And that feels really threatening to your brain. Your body is responding to that, responding to that threat, trying to process that. And it does that by activating that stress
你现在正在经历的。我们对过去戴着玫瑰色的眼镜，而对现在有着准确的视觉，这意味着现在感觉更加严峻。本质上，这个解释基本上说的是，远离你的家，即使是为了伟大的事情，即使是为了美妙的事情，最初总是意味着会有一段时间你没有一个可以立即回家的强烈地方依恋。这对你的大脑来说感觉非常具有威胁性。你的身体正在对那种威胁做出反应，对那种威胁做出反应，试图处理它。它通过激活那种压力来做到这一点
response. A stress response, your stress response, is basically just your body speeding things up internally to help you find a solution quicker, speeding up your thoughts, speeding up your nervous system speeding up all these things, hence why you feel anxious, hence why you idealize home, hence why you may be withdrawn socially, you may want to spend more time inside, you may not be sleeping well, you may not be hungry, you may be really worried, especially social and physical withdrawal. It's interesting, some researchers actually suggest this is a natural hermitting instinct when we feel homesick. It's trying to drive you to spend more time in whatever space you're in to become more familiar with it or to make it feel like home. That can obviously
反应。压力反应，你的压力反应，基本上只是你的身体在内部加速，以帮助你更快地找到解决方案，加速你的思想，加速你的神经系统，加速所有这些事情，因此你感到焦虑，因此你理想化家，因此你可能在社交上退缩，你可能想花更多时间在室内，你可能睡不好，你可能没有胃口，你可能非常担心，尤其是社交和身体上的退缩。有趣的是，一些研究人员实际上认为这是一种自然的隐居本能，当我们感到思乡时。它试图驱使你花更多时间在你所处的任何空间，以变得更熟悉它，或者让它感觉像家。这显然
not be great if that's the only thing you do, but all of this is this reaction to stress and to not having that homeostasis, that equilibrium. The confusing thing is that you don't always feel this way straight away, right, or all at once. That's because when we initially enter a new space or a new place, there is always going to be like a honeymoon or an adjustment period. basically there is always going to be a period where your brain is like this is really fun and still kind of thinks like oh we're just here temporarily like home is still home we'll be back there soon and because of that unconscious belief like you can kind of let loose and have a fantastic time like you're exploring you're meeting new people like you're trying your food you see the eyeful tower
如果这是你做的唯一事情，那可能不太好，但所有这些都是对压力和没有那种稳态、那种平衡的反应。令人困惑的是，你并不总是立刻感觉到这种方式，对吧，或者一下子全部感觉到。这是因为当我们最初进入一个新空间或新地方时，总是会有一个蜜月期或适应期。基本上总是会有一段时间，你的大脑会觉得这真的很有趣，而且仍然有点认为，哦，我们只是暂时在这里，家仍然是家，我们很快就会回去。因为那种无意识的信念，你可以有点放松，度过一段美妙的时光，就像你在探索，你在结识新朋友，就像你在尝试你的食物，你看到埃菲尔铁塔
I don't know like you're going out all the time you're trying on a new version of yourself and it lulls you into like a false sense of security of like oh I've avoided homesickness all together. Like, I really just got into the thick of it. It's always going to come. Whether it's for a minute, whether it's for a month, I found this when I moved to London. Honestly, I was so naive. All my friends were warning me. They're like, you have to be prepared. Like, you think it's going to be shit at some point. And I genuinely believed that I had avoided it. Like, after the first month or two, I was like, this has been easy. And only at like three months time, like, I was swiftly taken out. Like, it came for me. The way that it comes to every one of us. And the first wave of
我不知道，就像你一直在外面，你在尝试一个新版本的自己，它让你陷入一种虚假的安全感，觉得哦，我完全避免了思乡之情。就像，我真的只是进入了它的核心。它总是会来的。无论是持续一分钟，还是持续一个月，我搬到伦敦时就发现了这一点。老实说，我太天真了。我所有的朋友都在警告我。他们说，你必须做好准备。就像，你认为在某个时候会很糟糕。而我真诚地相信我已经避免了它。就像，在第一个月或两个月后，我想，这很容易。直到三个月的时候，就像，我被迅速击倒了。就像，它来找我了。它来到我们每个人身上的方式。而第一波
homesickness, this wave that I'm definitely experiencing right now, is often the worst because, again, you've been lulled into this idea that you're fine. You've been lulled into a false sense of security by the honeymoon period. So the emotional whiplash increases the intensity of all these really hard feelings. It can also be particularly brutal because I don't know if you're a university student, if you're at college, if there are all these other people around who have made the same move as you, sometimes like they're having a great time. They look like they're adjusting fine. They look like nothing is bothering them. And you're probably thinking like, why can't I be like these people? Why am I not finding this easy? The answer isn't just, you know, maybe they don't have as much to miss. It's probably because of the person you are. People who feel really deeply. People who are. People who are. People who are. sensitive, people who are in touch with the world, who are empathetic, who are big feelers, who are emotional, and I say that is a positive thing, often struggle more with adjustments like this, because they just feel everything on a bigger scale, including this nostalgia,
思乡之情，这一波我目前肯定正在经历的，通常是最糟糕的，因为，再说一次，你被那种你没事的想法所迷惑了。你被蜜月期带来的虚假安全感所迷惑了。所以情感上的鞭打增加了所有这些非常艰难感觉的强度。它也可能特别残酷，因为我不知道你是否是一名大学生，如果你在大学里，如果周围有所有其他和你一样搬家的人，有时他们玩得很开心。他们看起来适应得很好。他们看起来什么都没困扰他们。而你可能在想，为什么我不能像这些人一样？为什么我觉得这不容易？答案不仅仅是，你知道，也许他们没有那么多可怀念的。这很可能是因为你的为人。那些感受非常深刻的人。那些是。那些是。那些是。敏感的人，那些与世界保持联系的人，那些有同理心的人，那些情感丰富的人，那些情绪化的人，我说这是一个积极的事情，通常在这样的调整中挣扎得更多，因为他们只是在更大范围内感受一切，包括这种怀旧，
including the pain of saying goodbye, including the people they miss. It also means that when the time comes, when the tide turns, when things start feeling good, you're going to feel really good. Literally, you're going to feel this better than anybody. In 2014, there was an fMRI study done on this very thing that looked at the emotional processing of people who were self-reported, highly sensitive people and those who were not. And the hard emotions for them definitely registered hugely and enormously, but sort of the great emotions. Like the happy moods showed up so much more brilliantly in their mind and as a feeling compared to those who weren't as sensitive. So that's maybe a little bit of a silver lining to look forward to. It's hard right
包括告别的痛苦，包括他们想念的人。这也意味着当时间到来时，当潮水转向时，当事情开始感觉良好时，你会感觉非常好。字面上，你会比任何人更好地感受到这一点。2014年，有一项关于此事的fMRI研究，观察了那些自认为是高度敏感的人和那些不是的人的情感处理。对他们来说，艰难的情绪肯定注册得非常巨大和强烈，但伟大的情绪也是如此。就像快乐的情绪在他们的脑海中和作为一种感觉相比那些不那么敏感的人表现得更加灿烂。所以这也许是一个值得期待的一点点银边。现在很难
now, but it's going to be matched with such an amazing greatness on the other side. It's also really important not to fall too much into a comparison trap here just because you're experiencing this differently from somebody who moved six months before you or somebody else in your dorm doesn't mean it's something about you that you've made a mistake, right? It's not because the situation isn't right for you. Every situation, every person, I guess, just adjust at their own time and pace. And you know what, who knows? Those people are sometimes still in the honeymoon phase.
但它会在另一边与如此惊人的伟大相匹配。在这里不要陷入太多的比较陷阱也非常重要，仅仅因为你经历这种情况的方式与在你之前六个月搬家的人或宿舍里的其他人不同，并不意味着关于你有什么问题，你犯了一个错误，对吧？这不是因为情况不适合你。每个人，我想，只是在他们自己的时间和节奏下调整。而且你知道吗，谁知道呢？那些人有时仍然处于蜜月期。
That's why it looks like it's all working out for them. I remember when I was at college, I had this friend who, for like the first two years that we were there, she was having the best time. she was like the biggest like supporter of the university she had all the merch she would wear like her a new hoodie everywhere she was like the life of the party she was having such a great time genuinely she could have been the school mascot and then at like year two she was like I miss home so much like I don't know if I can stay here I genuinely was at time thinking like oh she's gonna she's gonna leave this person who was like the most pro who just seemed to be a adjusting better than anybody, the homesickness came for her eventually like it comes for all of us.
这就是为什么看起来一切对他们来说都很顺利。我记得我在大学时，我有这个朋友，在我们那里的前两年，她玩得很开心。她就像大学最大的支持者，她有所有的周边商品，她会到处穿她的新连帽衫，她是派对的灵魂人物，她玩得很开心，真诚地，她本可以成为学校的吉祥物，然后在第二年左右，她说我太想家了，我不知道我能不能留在这里，我当时真诚地在想，哦，她要离开这个人，她是最支持的，看起来比任何人都适应得更好，思乡之情最终还是来找她了，就像它来到我们所有人身上一样。
You simply just, you cannot compare apples to oranges. Your time and the time it takes for you to adjust is going to be different. So now that we kind of understand why homesickness happens, because it is a stress response, because of our sense, the sense of safety we need and the place attachment we need as humans, let's talk about when you should say like enough is enough. When do you know this isn't just homesickness, this is something else. And also, how can you deal with homesickness? How can you make yourself feel better during what is a very stressful time? We'll be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental
你根本不能把苹果和橘子进行比较。你的时间和你需要调整的时间将会不同。所以既然我们有点理解了为什么会发生思乡之情，因为它是一种压力反应，因为我们需要安全感和作为人类我们需要的地方依恋，让我们谈谈什么时候你应该说够了就是够了。你怎么知道这不仅仅是思乡之情，这是别的东西。而且，你如何应对思乡之情？在非常紧张的时期，你如何让自己感觉更好？我们将在短暂休息后回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上也有艾滋病，所以。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们仍然在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候我们已经做得足够多了。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现做一个好人很重要，当你活在地球上时。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们有。
have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, and sell insured the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，埃伦女士，你伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两名经历过
been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never. mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，永远不要。也招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜们》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。我感觉就像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he does. serves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎不在乎，所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的惩罚。去听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I have to be honest. So many of my recent experiences are really informing this episode today because I've been down bad with homesickness recently. And as much as London is amazing and you can post about it and make it look amazing, there have definitely been times where I've genuinely thought, like, what am I doing here? Like, why did I make such a stupid decision? I should go back to Australia.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我必须诚实。我最近的许多经历真的为今天这一集提供了信息，因为我最近一直深受思乡之情的困扰。尽管伦敦很棒，你可以发布关于它的内容，让它看起来很棒，但肯定有几次我真诚地想，比如，我在这里做什么？比如，为什么我做了这么愚蠢的决定？我应该回到澳大利亚。
The food is better. The weather is better. The lifestyle is better. The cost of living is better. Like, why did I give that up? What did I do this for? This is why everybody in the UK moves to Australia. It's better there.
食物更好。天气更好。生活方式更好。生活成本更好。比如，我为什么要放弃那个？我为什么要这样做？这就是为什么英国的每个人都搬到澳大利亚。那里更好。
There have been, I think definitely a lot of tears. It's been a lot of, like, panic, a lot of, like, asking my parents to send me photos of my dog, a lot of looking at apartments back in Sydney. And something me and my boyfriend have been discussing is like, when do we, when do you stop ignoring that feeling? When do you take that feeling as a sign? And I think right now we kind of know it's run of the mill home sickness, right? We've not been here for very long. It's going to run its course like any other sickness. But when do you make the call that like this may be something important to listen to? Here's what we decided. This is not professional
我想肯定有很多眼泪。有很多，比如，恐慌，很多，比如，要求我父母给我发我狗的照片，很多在悉尼看公寓。我和我男朋友一直在讨论的一件事是，什么时候我们，什么时候你停止忽视那种感觉？什么时候你把那种感觉当作一个信号？我想现在我们有点知道这是司空见惯的思乡之情，对吧？我们在这里待的时间不长。它会像任何其他疾病一样顺其自然。但什么时候你做出决定，比如这可能是一些值得倾听的重要事情？这是我们决定的。这不是专业的
psychological advice. This is just us talking about it, me sharing it with you. Obviously make your own decision here. But I think that if it's been more than a year, and if you have given this new place a really good shot, like you have really tried, if you've made some friends, if you've established a routine, if you've gone three months without visiting home, if this is not a momentary feeling, but something you feel at least once a day intensely, and it's not getting better, even gradually, then maybe it's not homesickness. maybe this is just not where you are meant to be. And that is a possibility within this. The thing is, I do truly believe that you can make a home wherever you are. But sometimes
心理建议。这只是我们在谈论它，我与你们分享它。显然在这里做出你自己的决定。但我认为如果已经超过一年了，如果你已经给了这个新地方一个很好的尝试，比如你真的尝试了，如果你交了一些朋友，如果你建立了一个惯例，如果你三个月没有回家，如果这不是一个瞬间的感觉，而是你每天至少强烈感觉到一次的事情，而且它没有好转，即使是逐渐地，那么也许这不是思乡之情。也许这根本不是你应该待的地方。而这在其中是一种可能性。问题是，我确实真诚地相信你可以在任何地方安家。但有时
it's just that you don't want to. And when you've really tried and you've really given it, you're all, and you've given it a shot, and the motivation still isn't there, then I think you're always going to be homesick. I don't know, maybe deep down you have no desire to call. this place your home. It just goes beyond this level of adjustment and of safety. Before you jump to that conclusion, because I think it's a very easy one to jump to if you are in the thicker things right now, I do think you owe it to yourself to commit as fully as you can for a period of time, just to avoid the what-if of like prematurely closing a door or finishing a story that is seconds away from getting good. I always say it takes three months
只是你不想。当你真的尝试了，你真的付出了，你的全部，你给了它一个机会，而动力仍然不存在，那么我想你总是会想家。我不知道，也许在内心深处你根本没有欲望称这个地方为你的家。它只是超越了这个调整和安全的水平。在你得出那个结论之前，因为我认为如果你现在正处于困境中，这是一个非常容易得出的结论，我确实认为你欠自己一个承诺，尽可能充分地承诺一段时间，只是为了避免那种过早关闭一扇门或结束一个距离变好仅几秒钟的故事的“如果”。我总是说需要三个月
to adjust to a new city, six months to feel okay about the decision, a year to decide whether it's the right decision, long term. And I think having that equation, having that timeline, or having like maybe even more so a deadline for when you can start reading into your homesickness is really helpful in this situation. Like this timeline, this formula, it also matches a lot of what we know about psychological adaptation after a major life change, like moving cities, like changing jobs, going through a breakup, whatever it may be, our emotional state is always going to spike. If it didn't, I'd be worried. It's always going to spike. Research though from the 70s shows that around the 3 to 6 month mark is when things start to return to what they call baseline
来适应一个新城市，六个月来对这个决定感觉还可以，一年来决定它是否是长期的正确决定。而且我认为拥有那个等式，拥有那个时间表，或者拥有，也许更重要的是，一个截止日期，让你什么时候可以开始解读你的思乡之情，在这类情况下真的很有帮助。就像这个时间表，这个公式，它也符合很多我们所知道的关于重大生活改变后的心理适应，比如搬城市，比如换工作，经历分手，无论它是什么，我们的情绪状态总是会飙升。如果它没有，我会担心的。它总是会飙升。然而，70年代的研究表明，在3到6个月左右的时候，事情开始回到他们所谓的基线
level. And that is what signals adjustment. Until then, you just have to move through this. Home sickness is like any emotion. It might feel terrible. I do also think it's trying to tell you something. It's telling you that you have a lot to be grateful for. It's also telling you that you're probably very scared, that you're very lost, you're very lonely. Addressing those feelings first and foremost, knowing that sometimes it just takes time is really where you have to begin.
水平。而这就是适应的信号。在此之前，你只需要度过这个阶段。思乡之情就像任何情绪一样。它可能感觉很糟糕。我也确实认为它试图告诉你一些事情。它在告诉你，你有很多值得感激的事情。它也在告诉你，你可能非常害怕，你非常迷茫，你非常孤独。首先解决这些感觉，知道有时它只是需要时间，这才是你必须开始的地方。
I think some people, and this is what I found, some people will tell you, like, your homesickness is lying to you. Like, just don't listen to it. It's lying to you. I don't think that's true. it's not that your homesickness is lying to you. It's not that there isn't something that you really do miss and you deserve to miss. It's just that it's only telling you one story.
我想有些人，这就是我发现的，有些人会告诉你，比如，你的思乡之情在对你撒谎。比如，只是不要听它。它在对你撒谎。我不认为那是真的。并不是你的思乡之情在对你撒谎。并不是没有你真正怀念的东西，你值得怀念。只是它只告诉你一个故事。
And it's only telling you the story of what you know, the story of what feels safe, the story of how amazing your friends are, the story of how much you miss your pets, the story of your routine. It keeps telling you how wonderful that all was because it was wonderful. What your homesickness is emitting, though, or making it hard. for you to see is how wonderful things could be. And the other story, the other situation that could also be told about where you are right now, which is that things get better, which is that things are going to start to pick up, which is that in a few months, you're going to start feeling
它只告诉你关于你知道的故事，关于感觉安全的故事，关于你的朋友有多棒的故事，关于你有多想念你的宠物的故事，关于你的惯例的故事。它一直告诉你那一切有多美妙，因为它确实很美妙。然而，你的思乡之情正在散发，或者让它变得困难。让你看到的是事情可能有多美妙。以及关于你现在所在的地方可以讲述的另一个故事，另一种情况，那就是事情会好转，那就是事情会开始好转，那就是在几个月内，你将开始感觉
more yourself, you're going to have a few more friends. And then one day, you're probably going to have one of those days where you're just like, everything is amazing. Like, that is the other story that you could tell yourself about the situation. Two months' time, you could have the best day of your life in this new place. And you could feel just as grateful for this experience as you do for the home that you love so much. Both stories are true. And the trick is, you need to focus on both of them at the same time. This sucks right now. I loved what I had. And also something I didn't even know I wanted and could love as much is going to come from this. There is something amazing. on the horizon. Hold both truths in either hand. Again, so much of this advice is very breakup
更像你自己，你会有更多的朋友。然后有一天，你可能会有那样的一天，你只是觉得，一切都很棒。比如，那就是你可以告诉自己的关于这种情况的另一个故事。两个月后，你可以在这个新地方度过你一生中最美好的一天。你可以对这种经历感到和你如此深爱的家一样感激。两个故事都是真实的。而诀窍是，你需要同时关注它们。这现在很糟糕。我爱我所拥有的。而且我也将从这里得到一些我甚至不知道我想要并且可以同样爱的东西。有一些美妙的事情。在地平线上。两只手都要握住两个真理。再说一次，这些建议中有很多是非常分手的
coded. Sometimes it's nice to think that way of like, you're grateful for the relationship that you had, but you know you could find better. It is a real psychological strategy. So to summarize that, don't let the urgency of homesickness and the urgency of your stress response convince you that you've made a mistake and that you need to remedy it immediately. Give yourself some time. Of course, if after a while, you know, it really isn't working, you can totally make the best decision. But just give yourself time to really commit to this and to this opportunity. I've learned so much about homesickness from all the times I've moved. So I want to give you some tips that I'm currently putting into play in my own life.
编码。有时那样想很好，比如，你感激你拥有的关系，但你知道你可以找到更好的。这是一种真正的心理策略。所以总结一下，不要让思乡之情的紧迫性和你压力反应的紧迫性让你相信你犯了一个错误，你需要立即补救它。给自己一些时间。当然，如果过了一段时间，你知道，它真的没有奏效，你完全可以做出最好的决定。但只是给自己时间真正致力于此，致力于这个机会。我从我搬家的所有次数中学到了很多关于思乡之情的知识。所以我想要给你一些我目前正在我自己的生活中付诸实践的建议。
things that are like general and also things that are more actionable that you could do like today. Firstly, and I think I said this in my seven tips for moving to a new city episode, but for the first three months, this is the biggest tip I will give you. If you can avoid it, do not go home. Again, keeping on this breakup metaphor, this is coming back many times. What is one of the best things that you can do after you break up with somebody in the aftermath of a breakup or a separation?
既有通用的建议，也有今天就能付诸行动的具体做法。首先，我想我在关于搬到新城市的七个建议那一期里提到过，但对于前三个月，这是我能给出的最重要的建议：如果可以避免，就不要回家。再次套用分手的比喻，这一点需要反复强调。分手或分开后，你能做的最好的事情之一是什么？
go no contact. And you need to go no contact with the place you miss. As hard as that is, they're not a toxic X. You probably will go back eventually. But it's important to do this to interrupt the detachment process. Otherwise, your brain is never going to fully clock into this idea that you are in a new chapter, you're in a new season. Every time you go back, there's a reinforcement loop at play. Seeing your old room, seeing your old friends, having your own routine, gives you a dope
断联。你需要和你怀念的地方断联。虽然很难，但它并不是一个有毒的前任。你最终可能会回去，但为了打断这种依恋过程，这样做很重要。否则，你的大脑永远无法完全意识到你已经进入了新的篇章，进入了新的阶段。每次你回去，都会触发一个强化循环。看到旧房间、旧朋友、过旧的日常，会给你一种多巴胺
been hit and it temporarily soothes a sense of longing, but that relief strengthens the initial craving because your self-control has weakened. Neuroscience research on breaking an attachment shows that reminders of a lost attachment activate the same reward and craving systems involved in addiction. The more you go back, the harder it is to move forward as terrible as that may sound. Secondly, I will say, find your old favorites in your new place. Make a project out of thinking about all the places that you really loved from your old home and finding the next best thing or the better thing where you are now. This was my number one priority when I moved to London.
冲击，它能暂时缓解渴望，但这种解脱感会因为你自控力的减弱而强化最初的渴求。关于打破依恋的神经科学研究表明，对失去的依恋的提醒会激活与成瘾相同的奖励和渴求系统。无论听起来多么可怕，你回去的次数越多，就越难向前迈进。其次，我想说，在你的新地方寻找你的旧爱。把寻找你旧居所中真正喜爱的地方的替代品或更好的选择当作一个项目。这是我搬到伦敦时的首要任务。
I knew I needed to find a gym, a nail salon, a local cafe, a local library that I loved just as much as the ones that I had left. With side note. This didn't go as well as I wanted it to. I found my dream gym. Honestly, a gym that was better than the one I had back in Australia. I was so excited for it. And it actually burnt down.
我知道我需要找到一个健身房、美甲店、当地咖啡馆和当地图书馆，要像我离开的那些一样让我喜爱。顺便提一下，这事儿进行得并不顺利。我找到了我梦想中的健身房，老实说，比我在澳大利亚的那个还要好。我当时太兴奋了，结果它烧毁了。
It burnt down within like this is not a made-up story. I got a year-long membership. It burned down two days later. So you can laugh. laugh otherwise you'll cry about this but commit to just finding the things that you know you really need in a location in this new place so that you have both that attachment to what you really loved and we're grateful for and also this new this new excitement for yeah how this is showing up in your new life thirdly i would say days that you are not feeling good
它真的烧毁了，这不是编的故事。我办了一年的会员，两天后它就烧毁了。所以你可以笑，不笑的话你就会哭。但要致力于寻找你在新地方真正需要的东西，这样你既能保持对过去所爱之物的依恋和感激，又能对新生活产生新的兴奋感。第三，我想说，在感觉不好的日子里，
whether it is today, whether it is in a couple weeks, get outside. First, get outside. Second, come back and get cozy. Both things are equally important here. You have to find the balance. I cannot overstate the importance of keeping busy and the importance of adventure in keeping the honeymoon period and the honeymoon phase of a new place alive and ensuring that you don't get stuck in convenient routines, not chosen routines. If you want to overcome your homesickness, you've got to treat every single day like it is your first day in this new city. You've got to play tourist. You've got to go out and do stuff. Literally, it was my 26th birthday the other day and I walked 26 kilometers across London just for the adventure, just to keep me focused on all the new things that I'm seeing
无论是今天，还是几周后，走出去。第一，走出去。第二，回来后让自己舒适起来。这两者同样重要。你必须找到平衡。我怎么强调保持忙碌和冒险的重要性都不为过，这能让新地方的蜜月期保持活力，确保你不会陷入方便但非自愿的常规中。如果你想克服思乡之情，你必须把每一天都当作你在新城市的第一天。你必须像游客一样去玩。你必须走出去做点什么。说真的，前几天是我26岁生日，我为了冒险在伦敦走了26公里，只是为了让我专注于我所看到的所有新事物，
and the opportunities and just the blessing of like getting to be here, right? And getting to see things I may have never seen if I hadn't had the opportunity to do this. Equally, equally, you need to keep showing your body and your mind that you are safe here, that you are comfortable. I see a lot of people like go all out with the adventure and then they burn out because they never spend any time at home. Your home is also important. You have to show yourself that you are comfortable here, you like it here, that this is a place that you feel safe. If you want one thing you can do today, go out on that big long walk of a new neighborhood you haven't explored yet. Give yourself like a $40 budget, whatever it is, and get some really cool, comforting stuff for your space.
以及那些机会，还有能来到这里的幸运，对吧？能看到如果我没有机会这样做可能永远看不到的东西。同样地，你需要不断向你的身体和大脑证明你是安全的，你是舒适的。我看到很多人在冒险上全力以赴，然后因为从不花时间待在家里而精疲力竭。你的家也很重要。你必须向自己证明你在这里很舒适，你喜欢这里，这是一个让你感到安全的地方。如果你今天想做一件事，那就去探索一个你还没去过的新街区，进行一次长途步行。给自己设定一个40美元左右的预算，买些真正酷且舒适的东西来装饰你的空间。
Buy nice bed sheets. I said this in my other episode on this. Buy nice bed sheets. Buy a nice lamp. Buy some pictures of home. Buy a cute trinket. So that this new home feels like a permanent one or feels like one that is comforting, feels like one that you want to be in.
买好的床单。我在关于这个话题的另一期节目里说过。买好的床单。买一盏漂亮的灯。买一些家里的照片。买个可爱的小摆件。这样这个新家就会感觉像是一个永久的家，或者是一个舒适的、你想待在里面的地方。
You need both things. You need the adventure. You need the novelty. You need the newness and the excitement of being in a place that, you know, ancestors of yours or other people that you know could only dream of. And then also making sure you have time to make your home, make your room, make your space, your safe space. So that your body does have that opportunity to decompress. this next tip is going to be the one that you probably hate the most, especially if you're really close with your family,
你需要这两者。你需要冒险，需要新鲜感，需要身处一个你的祖先或其他你认识的人梦寐以求的地方所带来的兴奋感。同时，也要确保你有时间把你的家、你的房间、你的空间变成你的安全空间，这样你的身体才有机会放松。接下来的这个建议可能是你最讨厌的，特别是如果你和家人关系非常亲密的话，
especially if you're really close with your friends, try to only call home once or twice a week. Maximum. This is going to be the hardest part. But similar to the above tip, you're essentially detoxing. This isn't forever, you know, just until like the calls become more sweet than bittersweet,
特别是如果你和朋友关系非常亲密的话，尽量每周只给家里打一两次电话。最多两次。这将是最难的部分。但类似于上面的建议，你本质上是在排毒。这不是永远的，你知道，只是直到通话变得比苦涩更甜蜜为止，
but it is so important I was on this Reddit page that was like homesickness and adulthood. And it was all these people giving these tips of like, call home as much as possible and talk to your friends and your family as much as possible. It's almost like drinking alcohol when you're really sad. Like it's going to make you feel really good and then it's going to make you feel really terrible. Or like eating like candy when you're really hungry.
但这非常重要。我曾在Reddit上看到一个关于思乡和成年的页面。上面全是人们给出的建议，比如尽可能多地给家里打电话，尽可能多地和朋友家人聊天。这就像在你非常难过时喝酒一样。它会让你感觉很好，然后会让你感觉非常糟糕。或者就像在你非常饿的时候吃糖果一样。
Like it's the thing that you is just there and it would just be the easiest way to satiate an urge or a need. and then you just realize it was probably a bad decision. And the reason is because it just keeps this again, it keeps this reinforcement cycle alive of like, when I'm feeling a bad feeling, the thing that's going to comfort me the most is home because that is better than anything I have here.
就像它是手边现成的东西，是满足冲动或需求的最简单方式。然后你才意识到这可能是一个错误的决定。原因在于，它让这个强化循环保持活跃，即：当我感到难过时，最能安慰我的就是家，因为那比我在这里拥有的任何东西都好。
And it's such a powerful urge because of course it is, but you have to deliberately try and break that if you want to be able to form a new attachment with this new city that you're in. I've been doing this as of a couple weeks ago. It's been really hard, but it's forced me to rely on new friends in the city and my boyfriend who lives here. And also it's forced me to rely on myself and to just be like, hey, I can actually handle
这种冲动非常强烈，因为确实如此，但如果你想与这座新城市建立新的依恋，你必须刻意尝试打破它。从几周前开始我就在这样做。这真的很难，但它迫使我依赖城里的新朋友和住在这里的男朋友。它也迫使我依赖自己，并告诉自己：嘿，我其实可以处理
this. And part of homesickness, again, is I think just being able to say to yourself, I can handle this and I can do hard things. I will also, this is like not really a tip, it's just advice. It's a movie recommendation, randomly. Watch the movie Brooklyn. If you are feeling intense homesickness right now, sometimes I think the, or any feeling, sometimes I think one of the greatest things we can do is seeing somebody else's story
这件事。思乡之情的一部分，我认为就是能够对自己说：我可以处理好这件事，我可以做困难的事情。我还要说，这不算建议，只是忠告。这是一个电影推荐，随机的。去看电影《布鲁克林》。如果你现在正感到强烈的思乡之情，有时我认为，或者任何感觉，有时我认为我们能做的最伟大的事情之一就是看别人的故事，
of enduring that and seeing that they turned out okay. It's basically like vicarious learning or like vicarious modeling, we would call it, in psychology. Basically seeing an example and knowing it's possible. possible for us, but this movie is incredible. It's with Sersha Ronan, I think it's based in New York, based in Ireland, about this young woman who moves from Ireland to Brooklyn. I'm not going to spoil it anymore. I feel like that's kind of a generic migration story, but it is so profoundly beautiful. And there is this quote in it that I think is just the best quote about homesickness,
看他们如何忍受这一切，并看到他们最终过得很好。这基本上就是心理学中所说的替代性学习或替代性建模。基本上就是看到一个例子，知道这对我们来说也是可能的。这部电影太棒了，由西尔莎·罗南主演，背景好像是在纽约和爱尔兰，讲述了一个年轻女性从爱尔兰搬到布鲁克林的故事。我不再剧透了。我觉得这是一个很通用的移民故事，但它非常深刻且美丽。里面有一句台词，我认为是关于思乡之情最好的引言，
which is like home sickness is like any other sickness. It's really annoying and it makes you feel wretched when you've got it and then pretty soon it will move on to somebody else and you won't be able to remember what it felt like. Any big emotion, you have to move through it rather than around it. And homesickness is no different. Anything you can do to feel it fully and then also know that this is just kind of part of the story and know that this is maybe just the price you pay for an incredible life and for a big life. This is the price you have to pay for a big life. This is the price you have to pay for a big is missing home, maybe even multiple homes, is a great mindset shift. Speaking of a mindset shift, this is the one that I will leave you with as a final thought.
那就是：思乡就像任何其他疾病一样。它真的很烦人，当你患上它时会让你感到痛苦，但很快它就会转移到别人身上，你甚至记不起那种感觉了。任何大的情绪，你都必须穿越它，而不是绕过它。思乡之情也不例外。任何能让你充分感受它，同时知道这只是故事的一部分，知道这可能是你为精彩生活和宏大人生所付出的代价的事情，都是好的。这是你为宏大人生必须付出的代价。这是你为宏大人生必须付出的代价，那就是想念家，甚至可能是多个家，这是一种很棒的心态转变。说到心态转变，这是我留给你的最后一点想法。
In your hardest times with this, in your hardest days, whether you're at college, whether you're traveling, whether you've just moved, I want you to remember that, and this is a weird thing I've noticed in my 20s, every great thing always asks us to give up something else we truly love and think is great. There is always a trade-off. Always. This new city, this new opportunity is fantastic. And it's going to be fantastic, but it's going to ask you to give up something else. You can't be too greedy with it. And the price that you are paying is homesickness, right? And it's a brutal cost. It's also temporary. And the alternative, the comparison, is the person that you know from high school, the person that you know from childhood,
在你最艰难的时刻，在你最艰难的日子里，无论你是在上大学，还是在旅行，还是刚搬家，我希望你记住，这是我在20多岁时注意到的一个奇怪的事情：每一件伟大的事情总是要求我们放弃我们真正热爱和认为伟大的其他东西。总是有权衡。总是这样。这个新城市，这个新机会是极好的。它会很棒，但它会要求你放弃其他东西。你不能太贪心。而你付出的代价就是思乡，对吧？这是一个残酷的代价。但它也是暂时的。而另一种选择，那种比较，是你在高中认识的人，你在童年认识的人，
that you know from university, who never did anything like this, and who maybe hasn't experienced the low of this feeling, but also has never experienced the high of that first day where it just suddenly feels great, or the high of meeting somebody you never would have met if you'd stayed where you were, the high of just having people over at the place that you now call home, of your parents coming to see your new life. So it's kind of this choice and this has nothing to do with homesickness and everything to do with life. If you want a big life, it comes with costs. If you want a small life, you might be more in the center of your emotional spectrum, I'm never experiencing such terrible lows, you're also probably never going to experience
你在大学认识的人，他们从未做过这样的事，他们可能没有经历过这种感觉的低谷，但也从未经历过那种突然感觉一切都好起来的第一天的高光时刻，或者从未经历过如果你留在原地就永远不会遇到的人，从未经历过在现在称之为家的地方招待朋友，或者父母来看望你的新生活的高光时刻。所以这是一种选择，这与思乡无关，而与生活有关。如果你想要宏大的人生，它就伴随着代价。如果你想要平庸的生活，你可能更多地处于情感光谱的中心，永远不会经历如此可怕的低谷，但也可能永远不会经历
such terrific, high, powerful moments of just feeling really capable, feeling like you've done the thing, feeling like, God, I'm so glad I've done this that can only come with hindsight. And it's hindsight that it's going to come to you. And I think part of this is me trying to say it to myself of like, this is hindsight that's going to come with my move to London. But I truly believe it. And I, yeah, and I just, I'm excited. And that's the, the feeling I try and replace my anxiety with is just excitement and optimism and possibility. So if you have made it this far, good luck. I know homesickness is really, really painful and really sad and I miss my mom and I miss my dog and I miss all my friends. So you are not in that boat
如此美妙、高昂、强有力的时刻，那种感觉自己真的很有能力，感觉自己做到了，感觉天哪，我真高兴我做了这件事，这些只能在事后回顾时才能体会到。而这种回顾会随之而来。我想这部分是我在试图对自己说：这是我搬到伦敦后会有的回顾。但我真的相信它。而且，是的，我只是很兴奋。这就是我试图用来代替焦虑的感觉，那就是兴奋、乐观和可能性。所以如果你已经读到这里，祝你好运。我知道思乡真的很痛苦，真的很悲伤，我也想念我的妈妈，想念我的狗，想念我所有的朋友。所以你并不是
alone and I'm also really, really proud of us. I'm really proud of you for doing the thing that is the hard thing. And I think you will most certainly be really. rewarded for that. If you have made it this far, leave a little comment down below. Where are you experiencing homesickness from? Are you in Paris? Are you in North Dakota? Are you in New Zealand? Are you in Kenya? Like, I don't know. Where are you listening to this episode from? I'd love to know. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram if you feel called to do so. Make sure you leave a five-star review if you related to this episode, if it helped you out and that you are following along for more. advice for your 20s. If you're in the US or Canada, you can also watch this episode, or all future
孤单的，我也真的、真的为我们感到骄傲。我为你做出了困难的选择而感到骄傲。我想你一定会得到回报的。如果你已经读到这里，在下面留个言吧。你是因为什么而感到思乡？你在巴黎吗？你在北达科他州吗？你在新西兰吗？你在肯尼亚吗？我不知道。你是从哪里收听这一期的？我很想知道。如果你觉得有必要，请确保在Instagram上关注我们。如果你对这一期有共鸣，如果它对你有帮助，请务必留下五星好评，并关注我们以获取更多关于20多岁的建议。如果你在美国或加拿大，你也可以观看这一期，或者所有未来的
episodes, if you don't want to rewatch this episode, on Netflix. Just look up the psychology of your 20s on Netflix. You will find us. You can see our studio. You can see my face. It's a very fun experience. Thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her assistance with this episode. She's amazing. But until next time, be safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
剧集，如果你不想重看这一期，可以在Netflix上观看。只需在Netflix上搜索“The Psychology of Your 20s”。你会找到我们。你可以看到我们的工作室。你可以看到我的脸。这是一个非常有趣的体验。感谢我们的研究员Libby Colbert对本期的协助。她太棒了。但下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的报应。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我支持你。在“Look Back at it”播客上。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我来说很重要。我是Sam Jay。我是Alex English。每一期，我们挑选一年，拆解发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
我不认为还有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听“Learn the Hardway”，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kier Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的诚实对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
但你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Learn the Hardway”。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，单身汉明星Clayton Eckerd被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。Owens女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人经历了同样的事情。Greg，一个女同性恋者。Michael Mancini。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的大脑被震撼了。我是Stephanie Young。这是“Love Trapped”。Scottsdale警察局。随着赛季的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。